nathan is in pittsburgh hi nathan
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for having me
sure what's up
so i started listening to your show
after i graduated college
my manager told me to look you guys up
and
start listening to some of the content
fortunately i was able to work at part
stores through college so i graduated
with
no student loans
i'm right now i'm on baby step six
i'm single i don't have kids so i'm not
worried about
baby step five i currently have
12 months in the emergency fund um
i lost both my parents so i don't really
have a
fallback plan if something major goes
wrong
my question is once i get the house paid
off
which i have about 64 000 left to pay
off
wow when do you start
i guess enjoying life and
how much do you look towards like the
retirement and saving that way
because i feel like right now all i'm
doing is
okay are you putting the 15 away for
your baby step four
yes i have 15 going to my raw final way
okay good
um and what do you make a year right now
i make about 70 a year
okay and you're how old again 25
okay wow you have done a wonderful job
nathan
congratulations you should you should
already be enjoying life
when you're at baby steps four or five
when you're at baby steps four five six
uh you you let your foot off the gas
you're not gazelle
intense and you begin to budget some
enjoyment items in there
while you continue to be intentional
about some of your other financial goals
but there's no reason at all that you
shouldn't
you know upgrade a car with cash or go
on a trip
if you can find a place that's open
and that kind of stuff and you know i i
you know i think i think you need to
give yourself permission
i don't know why why have you stayed so
intense do you think
uh well growing up my family never
really had money
so it's not just that mentality i saved
since i can remember
so did they talk about money or was
there stress or what was the deal
uh there was a lot of stress so my
parents they never really had money
um it was kind of just like a
work all the time but like a sore
subject
at your house yeah so they always taught
me to save
from a young age and i guess that kind
of just stuck with me even though they
didn't
yeah well they tried but they got into
debt in a failed business
yeah because i feel like a lot of your
caution nathan is not ending up back
like how
how you were right or how your parents
were you want to do something different
and that fear of going backwards is
scary to you
i would say um but i think that you've
put yourself in a great position
and i think you'll find i mean you have
12 months
of an emergency fund set aside which is
double what we recommend
but i can just tell out of the safety
and and the cautiousness in your voice
that
that feels good and then you're gonna
have to realize though that no amount of
money ultimately
is gonna bring you that security like
there's things to be wise about we talk
about it on here
all the time that you know you need your
emergency funds you need to be saving
for the future in retirement all of it
but but
once you start down the path that money
is ultimately going to be my security
i mean we meet people that are worth
multi-million
you know dollars and they still
can be frugal because they're so freaked
out of going back to where they were and
i don't we don't want you to live like
that at all so i think
you've been wise i think you've done
everything through the baby steps
and nathan i think you're gonna be great
i think you're gonna be fine i think
that there's a little bit of
breathing room you need in your life and
in your spirit and your emotions to
enjoy some of this money
and practice spending i think for some
people it is hard to spend but i would
say
put amount of money in the budget to say
i have to spend this because you're
gonna
yeah that practice is good that's a
really good idea and also add generosity
to your budget
if you will learn to spend on purpose
and it doesn't have to be a lot
but just go this amount of money is just
for pure
enjoyment this amount of money is for
pure
generosity i'm going to give this away
to somebody to something that's hurting
somebody out there
plenty of hurting folks out there right
now then those two things will loosen
you up a little bit
and move you away from uh
you know the fear that comes out of your
you know your
your family background and everybody's
got a family background too
uh that affects their spending you talk
about that in the new book know yourself
know your money
yeah and so which of the four types of
households was he from then
yeah he sounds like the anxious money
classroom a lot of stress but not a lot
of verbal communication around it
um and that's and it's a real thing i
mean like literally how you grow up
a kid can feel the stress in the air yep
and if you guys are not talking about it
but the stress is there
then that's the anxious money classroom
and if you grew up in that
then you're gonna have a tendency to do
this a lot of our money behaviors come
from
uh they don't have to but they can come
yes from how you were brought up and the
type of household you grew up in was it
a
secure environment was it an anxious
environment was it verbal
or was it closed down verbally but the
stress was in the air which is what
you're smelling there on that one yeah
yeah
and you cover that and know yourself
know your money right yeah digging in
and understanding and i like that he
even pinpointed back to
yeah this is this is where my fear comes
from because that is one of the
financial fears is i don't want to end
up like my parents
and i'm going to do everything in my in
my control
to not go back there and they passed
away yeah so he doesn't have a safety
net at 25. that's right
anybody can run back to so he's got that
extra emergency fund so
security's all over this discussion
absolutely it's all over it so very
very self-aware nathan you've done a
great job with money
um but you've also done a great job of
identifying that
it is now time to enjoy some of it uh
not go hog wild we're not going crazy
we're not going all the way back over to
the other side of the spectrum but
um but this is the right thing to do
hang on i'm gonna have kelly pick up
and we're gonna get you signed up for uh
a copy of rachel's brand new book know
yourself know your money comes out in
january
so don't expect it before then but we're
going to give you
a copy because you need to read through
it because it's exactly
the antidote for what you're facing is
to know yourself
and you know you talk about scarcity
versus abundance you talk about nerd
versus free spirit uh you talk about
savor versus spender
you talk about the fears that people
face with money all of those things
affect the money how you guys how every
one of us handle money
yeah it's it's a powerful thing when you
have the self-awareness of understanding
the why
why am i doing these things why are my
habits the way they are you can change
them and implement good habits
here you go it's good stuff